it's a great week for weed the two Super
Bowl teams from Washington and Colorado
are places where legalized weed is legal
that's the key there and President Obama
this week has caused a little bit of
commotion with something that he said
about wheat as has been well documented
I smoked pot as a kid and I view it as a
bad habit and a vice not very different
from the cigarettes that I smoked as a
young person up through a big chunk of
my adult life I don't think it's more
dangerous than alcohol so that last line
there that's that's the key line there
because I don't think it's much more
dangerous than alcohol actually
completely contradicts what is going on
on the whitehouse gov website so this is
the national drug control policies
official stance and again this is on the
official white house website the
administration steadfastly opposes
legalization of marijuana and other
drugs because legalization would
increase the availability and use of
illicit drugs and pose significant
health and safety risks to all Americans
particularly young people so on one hand
we have the president saying it's no
worse than booze than the other hand the
official White House stance is that it's
not very good Fauria it seems to me that
Obama is sort of doing what happened
with the gay marriage thing here
remember biden went on Meet the Press
sort of slipped with his support for gay
marriage and I think they're kind of
doing the same thing here it got to the
point where everyone's down with legal
weed Obama now kind of kind of slips
with something and now the wave just
begins I don't know is that manipulative
or my smoking something funny I mean
honestly I don't even think it's a slip
I think he's like this is my second term
it light it up you know I really think
that's what it is I think he's like it's
really not that serious guys just pass
it over here I mean you know I don't
think it is worse than alcohol alcohol
has you know medical research done that
is more destructive to your body and my
opinion and it's not because I'm biased
because I'm a smoke yeah i'm not sure
but yeah i think use your pinion and
factually based which are pretty sure it
is right right and they both go hand in
hand because i'm always right yeah so
yeah but no i really i really don't i
think he really is
throwing it out there it's I think it's
refreshing than he's coming with it
something he actually believes what he's
like yeah whatever it's not that serious
guys yeah I mean we all know that Obama
used to smoke a lot to eat I mean it's
well documented that he was smoking
plenty of weed when he was in college so
he sort of is this just you know he came
around like this is what politicians do
they wait till the numbers are there and
then they're suddenly brave yeah I think
it's really hard to completely imagine
the enormity of the Dragon's belly that
he stands in the center of and how many
influences he will enrage how many
people from pharmaceutical places and
you know that are connected to the
tobacco and alcohol people that are all
enormously threatened by this other
thing that could just clear the shelves
of their products if it ever went to
completely legal in those packets of its
soul people go wait this doesn't make my
dad beat anybody up and this is their
nicer and i'm hornier and all the things
i wanted all the hell with the rest of
these billions of dollars of other items
right on top of the stuff that you don't
get the side effects that you get from
all the pharmaceutical stuff oh the weed
you get the munchies yeah I think Nestle
should invest you know like things like
that like there needs to be a snack food
investment into a and the president's
opinion on this and ashley's munch yeah
exactly so let me just play some of the
Seas quickest the nestles semi slow yeah
exactly so let me play the cynic here
for just a sec do you think that at any
level maybe he's using weed as a little
bit of a distraction from say the
Obamacare site not being great still or
the NSA stuff that we're not happy about
that maybe he's like what can I sort of
latch on to that's like a popular thing
that'll kind of distract everybody I
mean it's such a cynic I am yeah I don't
know I don't think he's getting any
popularity points but I mean he's
getting popularity points from us i
don't think it's distracting is what i
mean i think that it just is what it is
i like how in the in the article it's
talking about how obama's talking in
circles and he's speaking loosely and
he's kind of contradicting himself i'm
like yeah cuz he's high
good yeah I I think that what's going to
be the irony is the thing that so many
of the people on the left are so worried
about will actually save it capitalism
will put marijuana on the shelves
nothing else the same amount of greed
that is attached itself to every other
popular item in our history will just go
and laser lock onto that and start
making that popular now that they know
it can be sold and they're going to and
they will throw tobacco under the bus
they will throw alcohol onto us and
tobacco and alcohol will go screaming
and kicking under that bus and that's
what we're in the midst of now you know
and their influence on advertisers and
news distribute distribution places
they're freaking out this is it's the
end of their era well isn't that the
irony of this shouldn't people on the
right though the libertarians who want
personal liberty shouldn't they be
backing legalized weed what you do in
your home to be legal and shouldn't the
people that care about fiscal
responsibility shouldn't they want it
because there's huge amount of tax money
to be made from this and yet for some
reason they they're not totally down
with it it seems to be still the
progressives and people on the left
there now what do you make of that we're
in the era of this that is the mac
remember the mac with the box a little
sad mouth off the other side that's the
mac we're at right now and year after
year that will grow until everything is
mac everywhere and just you know it just
seems like a small thing now but because
of the wall of money on the other side
of this thin this thin shell it crack
crack crack BAM out it comes that's it
once the the dam breaks and the money
flows into this state by state by state
will fall and the other states that
aren't making that money you're going to
flip out and kick everybody out that
doesn't make their stay like the one
across the way yeah and that's why i
compared to gay marriage because as
we've seen it all the things that people
say are bad about gay marriage none of
them turn out to be true and then it
turns out to be an economic boom in and
all that's a last question is do you
guys think that it's partly the
anti-drug people's fault that it's
actually becoming legal because they
looped weed in with coke and meth and
heroin so but then but then people for
cops keeping that off the street yeah
yeah but she made it seem like
everything is
equal and that if you try weed you're
automatically going to try heroin which
is just simply not the case o in a weird
way they strengthen the hand of the
people that wanted to legalize I mean I
don't see any like you know you've seen
that faces of meth thing I mean I
definitely haven't seen like faces of
pot you know it's just like a bunch of
people like with like a Snickers bar in
there yeah you can't love it in yeah do
you agree that they basically strengthen
the hand by putting all these things
together and they should have had if
they really wanted to keep weed legal
they should have had a strut a smarter
strategy and not lied about what we does
to a nation that has a population that
almost has entirely done it to know the
difference and they know when this one
they know when they're being lied to
yeah yeah I think that was a big mistake
they're using that 1930s hey I must play
the piano faster haha